see this is a thing I would definitely
do my neck I don't know about my face
I'm honestly planning to get a lot of
tattoos which is why I thought it was
really cool I was doing this because I
think it'll be funny to look back at
this and be like wow remember and you're
such a baby didn't have that many
because I'm planning on getting a lot
[Music]
first one I got was almost a year ago
maybe less than a year ago and I've
always wanted tattoos really bad but I
wanted to wait because I didn't want to
get tattoos like everyone else at them I
wanted to feel really specific and sure
about them this is real-life
affirmations I'm Lebanese so my dad
wrote them out for me in Arabic one says
I'm the child of the universe and I'm
infinitely creative the other one says I
would live to bring understanding and
beauty to the world and the third I will
not live in the past or the future that
I will always stay present my mom she
was always cool to be getting tattoos
but my dad never wanted me to get any
tattoos so this kind of why he got this
first one too because I was like hey
I'll get my first one you can write it
out you know what I'm saying
and then after that it's a lost cause I
got this one second the mission patch
for the trip that NASA's on I'm a
massive massive massive massive space
fan when I was on tour they took us to
NASA and it was like a kid at a candy
store it was like so incredible and they
actually let me on the floor in the
Mission Control Room
they've only let me and Garth Brooks
ever like touch the floor in that room
and apparently NASA told the guys in
space that I got a tattooed
they were like stoked they were like
gonna play cosmic first out and played
in space or something third one I got I
want to say was the arrows and
truthfully these don't really have any
purpose I just thought they look cool
everyone gets tattoos because they look
cool this is the first tattoo that I got
when I was in LA after coming home from
torrid the first tattoo which is kind of
good for LA because it's like a
meaningless place
you know this tattoo I got simple right
here in my arm simple is literally the
key to everything I do I always go back
to simplicity I always try and take
layers off stuff like a melody that's
incredible can sit by itself on an
acoustic guitar I'm obsessed with
symmetry in my music I like the balance
of everything to be perfect and to feel
like
just moving alongside each other you
know I'm setting a perfect speed and
tempo and I wanted to do the same of the
tattoos - that's what everything is
pretty concise of a moving piece this
was actually the first time I didn't
come up with the tattoo idea I met this
tattoo artist named Blas one of the most
talented artists transcending any career
path I've ever met I just like trusted
him because he was so incredible he's a
guy give me a sec and he like puts this
whole piece together and just shows it
to me and I'm like oh my god it's
amazing at the time I didn't know much
about Leonardo da Vinci who drew the
Vitruvian Man which is on my arm he was
centuries ahead of his time with his
ideas in his ideologies what's behind it
actually this isn't in the original but
Ruby man Balazs added that because he's
a genius it's just a palm with mercury
on it Apollo and Jupiter kind of faded
in the back on this hand which they
Vitruvian Anna sitting inside he
tattooed this and this took 12 13 14
hours I was so addicted I was like bro
you need to get me one more in the same
day I got this one on my hand right here
this one says I will love you forever my
dear found on my wedding finger and then
what's mine is yours across it I just
thought it's really cool that you know
one day I'll marry someone don't put
ring on the I love you forever my dear
finger or maybe I'll die alone and this
finger will always stay so I like all my
tattoos to be like if I lived in 400 BC
I can have these as like a tribal
warrior okay that's how I like to think
I like stuff that kind of transcend time
this right here is the Sun and then it's
the moon and it's basically coming from
two different worlds right so this is
like the roots of my existence these
three lines in Arabic the roots of who I
am and who I try and live by and then
the moon is like the nighttime of me
which is the music in the magic and the
creative they meet in the middle for the
yin and the yang you know what I'm
saying and I think everything in life is
kind of that balance of sound in moon
like darkness happy sad I got this one
when I was in Bali doing charity work
and there's this really cool tattoo
artist that I knew about the lines are
wavy and instead of notes there's
butterflies and they're stars because
music to me is a structural I've never
been the most technical musician but I
use it as a form to be creative it's
just like when I paint or do anything
like I'm not gonna draw the realist
picture of a face you've ever seen but
I'm gonna put passion and I'm gonna put
intensity into it and you're gonna feel
that every time so I got that to
represent you know music to me it's free
I may not be able to read know all the
notes but I'll put magic into every x GQ
what is good thank you for having me
thanks for checking out all my tattoos
next time you see me I'm gonna have a
lot more so remember this baby on